تعثر الاتفاق الايطالي بسبب قضايا عالقه
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع مطالب الجيش
السوداني دمج قوات الدعم السريع في فتره
اقصاها 36 شهرا من بعد التوقيع لا تكون
هناك اي قوه تاتمر بغير الجيش
يحدد الجيش انتشار قوات الدعم السريع في
العاصمه وخارجها اخضاع رتب ضباط الدعم
السريع لاعاده التقييم دمج استثمارات
الدعم السريع في المؤسسات الرسميه مطالب
قوات الدعم السريع مراجعه مناهج الكليه
الحربيه وتعديل شروط القبول فيها وضع نص
بالدستور وقانون للقوات المسلحه يلزم
القوات النظاميه بالنظام الدستوري ومبدا
الحكومه المدنيه ويجرم اشكال العنف
والانقلابات العسكريه فرض عداله في اختيار
المناصب العليا لقياده الجيش
دمج ضباط الدعم السريع بالرتب التي جاءوا
بها
منح امتيازات اجتماعيه للضباط وجنود الدعم
السريع